the rats are pulling on the you can
measure rat motivation by how hard they
pull on this on the spring let's say and
they're more motivated if they're
running away and running towards but
let's go back to play so you can take
juvenile rats who haven't been able to
play for a while maybe they've been
isolated or maybe they just haven't been
able to engage in physical activity like
many school children that you might be
thinking about neither allowed to play
nor allowed to engage in physical
activity and there's a reason I'm
telling you that so anyways you get one
of these little rats and you can measure
how hard he wants how hard it he'll pull
the go out and play or how many buttons
he'll push you know and that gives you
an indication of his motivation so
anyways you can see that the play
deprived juvenile rat will fight harder
to play than a non play deprived you've
now rat and so you can infer that the
rat wants to go play and you know you do
that you do the same measurement with
everyone around you if they want to do
something you're going to poke and prod
out them to see what sort of things
they're willing to overcome in order to
go and do that you'll object even if you
don't really object it's like it's a
measurement device and if they're
willing to overcome a bunch of your
objections then you think oh well maybe
they really want to and that's another
weird thing to really know if there's
something you want you need about five
arguments about why you want it because
the probability that the person who's
opposing you will have five arguments
about why you shouldn't have it is very
low
they just won't have thought it through
enough so the other thing that happens
in the future authoring exercise is that
you're asked to articulate the reasons
for all the goals that come out of your
vision of the future so you're asked
like why would it be good for you why
would it be good for your family why
would it be good for broader society so
that gives you three levels of
argumentation right there if you have it
articulated down into detail and it's
related to other important goals then
you're you're a hell of a thing to argue
with because people just aren't that
deep by which I mean they just don't
have that many levels of explanation or
objection and it's also really useful in
relationship to your own mind because if
you want to do something that's
difficult and that requires energy a lot
of different subsystems in your mind are
going to throw up objections it's like
well maybe that isn't
what you should be doing right now maybe
you should be doing the dishes or
vacuuming or watching TV or looking at
YouTube or if you're really sneaky when
you're trying to do something hard what
your brain does is give you something
else hard to do that's not quite as hard
so that you can feel justified and not
doing the thing you're supposed to
because you're doing something else
useful and if you give in to that
temptation which you often will then it
wins and because it wins it gets a
little dopamine kick and it grows
stronger everything anything you let win
the internal argument grows and anything
you let be defeated shrinks because it's
punished it doesn't get to have its way
so that's another thing really to
remember don't practice what you do not
want to become and because those are
their neurological circuits you build
those things in they're mad they're
they're not going anywhere you can build
another little machine to inhibit them
that's the best you can do once they're
in there you can't get them out so and
then the ones you build to inhibit can
be taken out by stress and the old
habits will come back up so you've got
to be careful what you say and what you
do because you you build yourself that
way